-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from her work on
the HBO hit series "Girls."
She stars in
the critically acclaimed series
"The Flight Attendant," which is
currently streaming on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Take a deep breath.
-[ Gasps ]
-And then -- you're okay.
-No, I'm having a panic attack.
-No, you're not having
a panic attack.
-I'm having a panic attack.
-Jessica!
-Who are you --
Who is that?
You're calling your assistant?
That's Jennifer.
-How would you know that?
-Yep.
-Jessica, grab Cassie
a Topo Chico
from the back of the fridge.
-Jennifer -- Wait. Topo --
A Topo Chico?
You have those on hand for me?
-I love you.
Um, they're for me.
'Cause why would
they be for you?
'Cause, you know,
you've never been here.
-Please welcome back
to the show Zosia Mamet.
♪♪
-Yay!
Hello!
Now we can touch.
We can touch.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Welcome!
It's great to see you!
-Thank you!
It's so good to see you, too.
-Now, Zosia, this is --
I think this is the first time
you've been --
Because you obviously have done
a lot of press
for this very popular show.
-Yes.
-But this is the first time
anything's been in person
for you.
-This is. I actually --
I just went to wave,
and then I was like,
"Nobody's there."
I'm waving at --
Unless there are ghosts.
-We do not --
We've been trying to get ghosts.
-Oh, yeah.
-Because all the shows
want them.
-I know. It's so high demand.
-In so demand, I know.
It's okay.
I heard Jimmy
has ghosts, but, yeah.
-Yeah, Jimmy.
Well, NBC said we can only
pay for ghosts for one show.
-Oh, okay. Cool, cool.
-You know.
-So I didn't get them?
-No, sorry.
-Okay. No, that's fine.
-How -- Was it nice?
I was just talking
with Graham Norton
about how some people are happy
to be back doing talk shows
because it means they can
just, like,
have a reason to go out.
-Yeah. Yeah.
No, totally.
And, also, like, wear clothing.
-Yeah.
-You know?
'Cause I've just been, like,
basically, you know,
in underwear from like
here down 'cause Zoom is just...
It's been so nice.
It's been nice to, like,
see people and interact.
-I will say, when people ask me,
because I don't mind
talking to people on Zoom,
but one of the nice things is --
I don't get to actually see them
before the show.
And it was so nice to be able
to go back in the dressing room
and talk to you,
and so that's the part
I miss the most about Zoom.
-Yeah, just, like, interacting
with human beings.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause you can't crawl
through your camera.
-No.
-Apple hasn't
done that for us yet.
Which, honestly,
I really thought they would.
-It's like, "Come on, guys.
Catch up."
-I know.
I was like, "Hello?
Can you guys --"
-This was the year to do it.
-"Can you...?"
-Speaking of --
You were very
ahead of the curve.
I want to applaud you.
-Oh.
-Because last time
you were here, pre-pandemic...
-Yeah.
-...we talked about how
you rented an RV.
-Yeah.
-And you drove across country.
-Yeah, I did.
My husband and I
and our dog Moose.
I had to --
the show that I had done before,
"Tales of the City,"
was premiering
at the San Francisco
Film Festival.
And we realized
we had about three weeks,
and so we had always
wanted to do that.
We had had a belated honeymoon.
We rented an RV.
We drove there and back.
-Wow.
-And that was --
I came on the show
right after that,
right after we got home.
And funnily enough,
I was speaking to your producer
yesterday, and she was like,
"So let's talk about that."
And I was like --
Literally, my husband
was sitting next to me
googling RVs,
because "Flight Attendant,"
season two, shoots in L.A.,
and we don't want to fly
with our dog,
and so we're about to buy an RV
and do it again.
-I see --
I'm a little bummed,
Because I had hoped
that you had bought an RV
before the pandemic.
'Cause I feel like you're in
a situation where you're gonna
be, like, buying Bitcoin now.
Right?
The RV, it must be a booming --
-I just -- Look, you know,
nobody's perfect.
-Right.
-Like, I'm honestly also upset
that I didn't invest in Oatly,
but, like, 2020 hindsight.
You know?
-Yeah, right.
-So, like,
I'm definitely kicking myself
for both of those things.
But, um...
-But you're gonna
live that RV life again.
-I'm still --
We're still gonna do it.
You know?
-That's great.
-I think he's, like,
on Facebook Marketplace, like,
negotiating with some woman
named Betty in Upstate New York,
being like --
-Is your --
I'm married to the negotiator
in our relationship.
Is your husband the negotiator?
-Oh, 1,000%.
-Yeah.
-I'm the one, someone's like,
"I'll give it to you
for five times the price,"
and I'm like, "Sold! Great!
I'm so sorry.
Do you also want me to, like,
pay you more
and, like,
dance and also apologize?"
-Yeah.
-He's like, "What did you do?"
What do I --
He always laughs at me,
because I say --
I get the saying wrong.
I'm like, "It's a steal
at half the price."
And he's like,
"Yes, it would be."
[ Both laugh ]
"But that's not
the actual saying."
-Yes.
-So that's -- yeah.
-It's nice to be married
to a negotiator.
-It helps a lot, for sure.
-Congratulations on this show.
-Thank you.
-Which I'm saying backstage
I feel like was a show
that showed up
at the perfect time for people
who are desperate
to watch something new,
and it felt very unique.
And one of the things that seems
genuinely great about it
is that you were very close
with the people
you worked on the show with
and very appreciative.
'Cause you started, stopped,
and started up again.
-Yeah.
We got incredibly lucky.
It was also insanely --
It was, like, some crazy kismet.
We literally had just wrapped
our fifth episode.
We did eight total.
So they were able to do post
on our first five
during the pandemic,
totally remotely,
which was super wild.
We had, like, a few reshoots.
But so many shows were getting
canceled left and right.
Basically, HBO Max and Warner
kept saying, like, "Don't worry.
We promise we'll let you
finish the season."
Which even just knowing
throughout the pandemic --
no one knew
when it was gonna end --
knowing that we had that to go
back to --
And I'm super jaded,
and I didn't believe it
until we got there.
But we did.
We got to finish our season.
And we felt so lucky
'cause we had had all this time
shooting together already,
so we created
this creative shorthand,
and we had these relationships.
We all, like, genuinely knew
and loved each other.
And so when we went back
under the umbrella of shooting
with these new COVID protocols,
we had, like, this --
You know, we had created this --
these friendships already,
and so it didn't
feel strange or scary.
Like, I mean,
we all were worried it would,
but then we got on set
with each other,
and everybody
just, like, jumped in.
-And you managed to do --
I guess Kaley
gets credit for this.
You managed to do a wrap party
with social distancing.
-Yes. Kaley refused to not
let us not have a wrap party.
I think it took us
like a year and a half
to shoot eight episodes.
And, you know,
we're not "Game of Thrones,"
so that was surprising.
-Right.
-And so, yes.
We social-distanced.
We all wore masks.
-And then, it seems the gifts,
the wrap gifts
are very unicorn-themed.
-Yeah.
So I feel like I --
I feel like I've always been
a unicorn lover,
but it really just --
I feel like I really, like,
told the world this year
that that's inside.
I finally like -- I admitted it.
-It was a good year to, like,
admit a secret about yourself,
because so much was going on
that nobody could overreact
to the fact
that you were a unicorn lover.
-I think so.
Yeah, I just -- I was like,
"You guys, I love unicorns!"
And everybody was like,
"Okay, cool."
Yeah.
So, Kaley gave me my wrap gift,
which included something special
and also
all of those unicorn things.
-Yeah, it was really lovely.
And it's such a good show.
-Thank you.
-And it's so lovely
to see you again.
-It's so lovely to see you.
-And thank you for making
the time and coming here.
-Thank you for having me.
-You guys,
"The Flight Attendant"
is available to stream now
on HBO Max. She's in it.
She's wonderful.